Narrator: Dentures.
They're often used as comic relief
in movies and Pixar animated shorts,
but they play a big
part in the daily lives
of about 20 million people in America,
and it's not just older
people wearing them.
But how exactly are they made?
Dentures have come a long way.
This set took two fittings and was shipped
between two locations
before it was ready to wear.
The first thing to know is
that a full set of dentures
has a flesh-colored acrylic
base that fits over the gums.
The upper portion covers
the roof of your mouth,
and the lower is a horseshoe shape
that accommodates the tongue.
Now that we know the basics,
let's learn how dentures are made.
First, a prosthodontist
makes an impression
to capture the patient's
upper and lower gums.
A thick paste gets placed
into the patient's mouth
for a few seconds.
While the impression is still gooey,
it's poured into a stone,
which acts as a cast.
This cast is now a replica
of the patient's mouth,
which comes in handy
during the final stages
of creating the dentures.
In the meantime,
the patient tries on
different sets of dentures
to determine the size and color
of their soon-to-be teeth.
From there, the prosthodontist
makes a few adjustments to the cast.
Next, the cast of the
mouth is sent to the lab
where the dentures get made.
Using the patient's cast as reference,
the lab starts to create the
wax version of the gum line.
The teeth, made of acrylic resin —
a material that looks very
similar to real teeth —
are set in place.
Minor touches get made to
the wax around the teeth
then get sent back to the prosthodontist.
After the wax dentures are approved
by both the patient and the
prosthodontist for fit and look,
they're sent back to the
lab to finish the process.
The wax is just temporary.
It gets replaced by an acrylic,
which is more aesthetically pleasing
and realistic-looking.
The lab boils the dentures to
get rid of the wax portions.
Holes are indented into the teeth
so the material can attach to it.
Then, a machine called the IvoBase
injects the acrylic liquid into the molds
to stick to the denture teeth.
The dentures are cleaned up and polished.
They're now ready for the patient.